and around half a million people who  have severely weakened immune systems  ought to be offered a third dose of the  coronavirus vaccine people with  conditions such as leukemia or advanced  hiv and those who've recently undergone  organ transplants will be given the jab  the announcement is separate to any  decision on a booster program  we've accepted the advice of the  independent jcvi and they've been very  clear that this third dose should be  offered to anyone over the age of 12  that has a severely weak immune system  and that's exactly what we're doing of  course we keep this under review at all  times and should their advice change at  a later date to include a different  group of people of course we would  follow through on that advice